Optum care lung and allergy Care the
sponsors of this segment is back to tell
us how to take care of allergies here in
southern Nevada Rocky spoke to a doctor
to learn more Dr vanuya welcome back
good Morning Rocky hey so I know when we
see you we're talking allergies
um what's what's new in the allergy
department at Southwest Medical well I
have some exciting news uh We've added
two new board certified allergists which
makes our allergy department here at
Optum uh probably the biggest in Las
Vegas so we now have three locations
what are the Southern Nevada allergies
that we need to look out for so let's
start off with the basics with allergies
because it's very timely it's the fall
allergy season
here in Nevada just like in any other
part of the United States we have
seasonal allergies and here we have
springing and Fall allergies and we also
have perennial or all year round
allergies but specifically in the fall
we're now dealing with a lot of pollen
allergy from Ragweed weeds molds and of
course we have the all year round
allergens in cat and dog dander and dust
mites now Dr Vernier is there more to
allergies than just the runny nose or
the itchy eyes that we should know about
unfortunately one of the most dreaded
complications of allergies is asthma so
if you have allergies you are two to
three times more than likely to develop
asthma having allergies also
predisposes a person to recurrent colds
middle ears sinus infections it's the
number one cause of kids needing tubes
in their ears for repeated ear
infections and having their tonsils and
adenoids taken out it can contribute to
snoring poor sense of smell frequent
headaches and believe it or not 40
percent of people who need orthodontic
braces may have allergies because if
you're chronically mouth breathing you
can have an overbite
and also allergies can cause a condition
called nasal polyps which is a benign
growth in the nose what is the best way
that we can respond to these symptoms
that we potentially do
so now that we've talked about why do we
need to treat allergies let's talk about
how do we treat allergies there are
three ways number one is to identify
what you're allergic to and stay away
from it and in most cases it's very
difficult to do but certain tips include
uh not opening Windows specially in the
high pollen season
and of course if we have pets at home
again to regularly groom uh our Lovely
Pets so that it will decrease dander
exposure in our homes now in terms of
the second way to treat allergies it
will be mainly medications but
medications are Band-Aids mainly it's
like treating Tylenol your fever with
Tylenol without addressing the cause of
the fever it's just masks symptoms it's
allergen immunotherapy has always
remained the most definitive treatment
option for allergy sufferers and that is
a treatment where we give you what
you're allergic to in graded amounts
until your immune system can protect you
against the things that are causing
allergies
thank you to Optum care lung and Allergy
care for sponsoring this segment if
you'd like more information you can call
that number
702-724-8844 or visit lung
andallergy.com
furniture